what's up guys I'm so excited because
some of you may have seen my first
attempt at long boarding ever it was
pretty terrible so I decided to take the
Playtex sport challenge and challenge
myself to become a better boarder does
that the better border is that of a
better skater now to do this challenge I
was so excited because I found out that
my friend Evelina also wants to be a
better skateboarder so we were about to
take this challenge that are you ready
for this I'm still ready for this so
you're gonna be doing more tricks yeah
yeah I'm gonna try to do like some kick
flips and tricks and just kind of you
know do more badass things true skate
now yes all right let's go oh today
girl you gotta get geared up
I'm jumping off the board I think I'm
just gonna try to like hold myself up
guys I am absolutely exhausted but I had
so much fun so thank you so much I like
Wiley for challenging me on this plate
exports challenge now my turn I am
challenging Blogilates and so I cannot
wait to see what you decide to come up
with and don't forget to check out
Evelina's channel for her skateboarding
video she's actually doing tricks
whereas I didn't really do any tricks so
thank you guys for watching I love you
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
I'm gonna go to sleep
you